hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alba this is Amy castle Amy
castle from its Amy castles her YouTube
channel Amy it's Halloween it's not yet
it's coming up Donna's right I'm Anna
poncho brush Halloween I can't handle it
costco it's already have you ever been
on the Deep Web I've seen some of your
videos on the Deep Web yeah what rousing
stories found on the internet I mean
okay sometimes I get two in the morning
I just get on the web and I'm stuff and
it's a rabbit hole that's very deep web
is is a great place to go I'm telling
you the most positive filled inducing
videos we'll ever see and I'm hoping top
five unknowns really explores that no no
no I'm the last thing from a liar is
what he said as he is often highly
regarded as one of the most disputed
mysterious areas of the internet isn't
necessarily any more dangerous than this
surface web it's anonymity certainly
does entice some pretty strange people
in business I'm already excited this was
back before Google web pages were for
the most part still very basic HTML with
JavaScript yeah
hardly anyone used CSS only discussion
boards and some baking sites had any
approaching mature front-end or back-end
combinations this is technically a real
Deep Web story just not one about
illicit activities online okay I was
crazy and random blogs geo city sites
and the like just going from link to
link eventually I came upon an odd page
it appeared to be random thoughts from
different people but for the time it was
very well designed the messages seem to
be cryptic in nature like several people
trying to pass secret notes I started
through the source and hidden in the
comments of in JavaScript were various
IP addresses I
all of the IP addresses in a text file
and began a numerating some were routers
with banner messages I could tell that
to almost all at universities they
default Cisco credentials from back in
the day worked on most of them but I
didn't really poke around a few of the
IPS were from web servers with little to
nothing on them mostly apache or linux
or some bsd at least one iis server I
can recall I finally came upon a web
page with a huge directory of HTML files
and TIFF images with a few smaller sub
directories containing the same a DNS
lookup returned no reverse records for
the IP a visual router ista as far as
Colorado the HTML files appeared to be
records of a psychologist or a similar
mental health professional linking the
images were of faxes apparently both
military and medical nature I said was
some directory back to the parent at the
top of the page was a new HTML file
named one - hello there HTM Oh what he
said was from right at that minute I
open it up and in plain text there was a
message saying we see hey no quotes all
lowercase Oh about 15 seconds later the
server dropped that's my job so I spent
pretty much every day for the past four
or five years digging around in there
I've sat through fake rec rooms had fake
hitmen trying to bribe and then fright
me into taking down my stories about
them and had it counts on every major
online black market that ever existed I
do a little crawl every few days to see
what new sites have popped up and visit
most of the most frightening experience
I have ever had is coming face to face
with Lux the owner of pet Oh Empire and
hurt to the core the most evil and
reviled person on the entire camp he was
responsible for procuring and hosting
Daisy's destruction the most repulsive
video ever made created by Peter Scully
whose crimes were so bad the Philippines
are considering reinstating the death
penalty especially for
whoa it wasn't frightening because Lux
was frightening he was anything but it
was frightening because he looked so
inoffensive and normal it was
frightening because he was living proof
that monsters such as Lux walk among us
and we may never know you looking for
that video yeah okay when I was still
under age 14 to be exact I started to
learn about the deep web or dark web or
whatever it started out as me being cool
because I was able to access it or
whatever when I showed my friends also
to look at drug prices on different
websites and you know eventually I
discovered the CP network and well as a
teenage boy I started visiting the chat
rooms pretty often I didn't say much
just watch the creepy old men talk about
different things sometimes they were
being link dumps of hundreds of
different CP I tried resisting from it
knowing it was wrong but but I didn't
hold out long with my tendencies I
started visiting the rooms more often
and getting to know more of the people
on them I even started talking to a few
of them I can't remember when but one
day I started talking to a guy who asked
me how old I was I don't know why I
didn't lie and tell him I was 49 or
something but I said fifteen well he
just so happened to have an interest in
me yeah I kind of enjoyed talking to an
older man I ended up sending a few
pictures to him and he logged off
shortly after a few more people messaged
me the next night and the next and so on
I probably sent hundreds of pictures and
some videos of me using a crappy webcam
I had I talked to some of the darkest
and most hated people on earth and I
didn't think twice about it it all came
to an abrupt end when my PC died and I
had to wait a couple months to get a new
one I had thought about it a lot and
decided it wasn't best for me to keep
talking to these types of people
in storm ABC I've never been able to
tell anyone that's due to its nature but
it feels good to get it off my chest
whoa you like temps it's him pedophile
yeah I first learned about the Deep Web
back in grade 10 when it's really
strange druggie kid in my grade was
going on about we sat together in
English and had a new teacher that
wasn't very good and didn't really know
how to control the class so the last 20
minutes or so she just let us do
whatever everyone around this kids desk
let's call him Eli would crowd around
his computer and watch him monkey around
on this Silk Road and other websites
that he found no CP or anything but
drugs and hitmen and just weird things
in general I was kind of freaked out by
it so I tried to avoid looking but I
listened and it was pretty strange
eventually Eli decided to wear drugs
from some site this is high school so we
all lived at home so he figured he would
order the DMT up to his cottage go out
for a weekend and pick it up and hide it
in his closet
so he typed in his address to some guy
worked out the details and waited he
went up to his cottage the next weekend
and we all waited for him to return with
his stories you I got back and he all
right out to ask if it worked he said it
didn't and he was really upset since he
had already paid the guy he complained
to whoever was selling him the drugs and
the guy was really understanding and
assumed the package was intercepted by
the post office he said he would send an
even bigger package to his cottage this
time to make up for Eli went up the next
weekend but still nothing the guy then
told him once again that he would send
another package but still nothing
he might gave up and figured the guy was
just trying to make a quick buck he left
me to grab and that was that though
months later Eli went up to his College
with his family and had a big dinner
party with the whole complex of cottages
he was wandering around when he
overheard a group of elderly people
talking about calling the cops he
stopped and asked them why and they told
him they said that they had been
consistently getting shipments of drugs
every week turns out Eli had just typed
in the
address he was talking to had been
sending more and more to the wrong
people
each home super freaked out about this
and honestly a little bit upset though
his since given up on the whole idea of
drugs and is doing quite well for
himself one I lived in a fraternity
house my junior year with about 16 other
guys and about 45 in the chapter overall
we had actually been arguing about drugs
in the house about half of us were
saying that allowing drugs was simply
asking for trouble and the other half
wanted to use the Charter house as a
haven from campus security early on in
the school year a couple guys asked me
and some of the other internet savvy
people about the Deep Web I explained to
them that it wasn't interested in
helping as they simply wanted to order
drugs and I didn't really hear anything
else about it for a while though after a
few months some of the guys started
talking about buying things off the Silk
Road I assumed they were just lazy and
trying to get cheaper weed or shrooms or
something turns out I was incorrect they
had ordered about five thousand dollars
of MDMA and acid is paint away on a
sunny afternoon and when tomorrow
members of Homeland Security
Investigations raided our home I was
upstairs overlooking the parking lot and
a bunch of guys were outside getting
ready to go going I watched a car pull
up slowly followed by another one that
was bolting around the corner the guys
on the ground told me that the driver of
the second car got a little too excited
apparently he jumped out of the car with
a Taser drawn and screamed quote get on
the ground or prepare to feel the
Thunder in the parking lot so they could
search the house I still had no idea
what was going on at this boy after a
little while they explained who they
were and what they were after the
aftermath was two guys that got arrested
on felony drug traffic one got arrested
on minor
possession he arrested but didn't charge
a fourth guy he was the one whose house
the drugs were sent to but the guy
genuinely had no idea what was in the
packages another two guys got suspended
for a year for suspected involvement
Indian the two main guys got house
arrest for a year and probation for five
years the other guys all transferred
except for one who didn't get charges he
was released and graduated on time as
for the rest of us we got our charter
revoked and everyone just left it alone
otherwise younger people around the
campus are mostly scared of us now
because the AML made it sound like we
were a violent drugs camis go away well
what I've learned is you get on the
ground or prepare to feel that's take
away two top five unknowns guys they're
a great channel the first one was insane
Oh see you guys that's crazy I can't
tell you how many girls I've done that I
mean I was into this normally when I see
Toph I have unknowns it's not stories of
what this guy's actually been through I
think it's a group of people that do
top500 okay so they're all telling me I
think so I'm not sure normally they have
like list videos just compose about
certain incidences or whatever or facts
this is the first time where I'm like
whoa I'll fire these stories are coming
from this guy's own personal life
okay I'm exploring the Deep Web that's
pretty nuts to come across like go
through all these like bunch of
terminology I don't understand yeah and
then come across a message that was
linked to a psychologist this is we see
you I would never go on the Deep Web no
I would never do deep you can't get out
oh that's what it seems like what
happened with this guy keep telling
these stories I'm like this guy needs to
get off the deep
okay some deep stuff yes that's it went
way way too far I think about like how
many other kids might have been involved
in something like that that to be 15
years old and then you're talking to
someone and you just feel like oh it's
kind of cool getting approval of like an
older person I don't really you know
you're not really comprehending what the
hell's actually happening at this point
you know a lot of us grow up with the
idea to you know respect the elders and
older people like you that means you're
cool or something like that I mean I
know I had that fit I was younger I can
only imagine how many other kids who
could access the Deep Web got involved
in situations like this yes because he
said he's sent like hundreds of photos
he didn't say what photos they know I
mean even if it's just her face you're
spreading on that is so disturbing to
know how yeah that's like it's like a
pedophile community out there very
disturbing very creepy but very
well-made video very well-made video
yeah it allows you to put together a
good YouTube you know it's a great video
why'd you have these experiences so you
can share them with us it's a good thing
you got that off his chest I guess yeah
I can imagine how the having something
like that can make you feel a little
like weirdly shameful even though you
didn't do something wrong you know just
like a part of it yeah but it can feel
like in some ways it's a form of sexual
abuse oh that is awful to have to go
through something like that these are
all true series but I love the guy I
love the story about like family members
got all this we keep getting all these
charged so we are like normal civilian
everyday version of that is when you
order something on Amazon and it shipped
the wrong but this is drugs it's like a
comedic story to me I'm just should be
the drugs you gave me the address I can
only imagine
although you realize how funny that
story is you think the guy got clean
after that recording the narrator
man he got caught he got terrified he
got clean F to put that with the end so
you feel a little better yeah because
this video
that's an uplifting story yeah in my
opinion we keep getting these drugs we
did it we should call the cops oh man
what a awkward sin are you I would love
it if the family members got the drugs
and they just started using the drugs
you can imagine for a drug addict just
like free drug we're gonna keep can't
get my hands on shrooms or ecstasy I
have so many friends who do all that and
I'm like I don't want to try some that I
never get to go to the Deep Web bounce
what you've learned in order to get the
drugs I desire I have to get stuff
unfortunately not you think you could
you think there should be some Deep Web
App Store Deep Web mate or you can yeah
where you can get like some delivery
service Wow that would you want how cool
that be any amount that's the future I
had one shroom get one free I think that
that's the next step instead of having
to go to your computer and get a PC to
access the Deep Web there's gonna be a
Deep Web within the App Store a deep app
store where you get those mates for
drugs whoa that would be really crazy if
I lived in a world when that is I could
finally try shrooms you could finally
try shroo
I hear it's great I don't know although
I did hear one story about a guy who
thought hair was growing out of his
eyeball so he started shaving his
eyeball
I just gave me a physical visceral
feeling and she can't feel your eye
contact it already has detachment
eyeball way too often over a contacts
too I'm mad enough to shoot I feel a
tingle in my yes we've all had the
feeling of Shaving well I think that's
gonna be the app I work on huge did you
do you deep dark I don't I will stick to
other things would you call that app
what are the delivery apps called maybe
this is going to end up on the deep yeah
go shoot things like that I'm not joking
I'm being 100% serious
what do you have series I don't know the
next part to that well top 5 unknowns
thanks for the interesting tale and
appreciate you bearing your terrible
stories alright well you guys can
subscribe to top 5 unknown subscribe to
the real rejects and click that
notification but more importantly follow
Amy castle it's Amy castle on Instagram
Twitter and more importantly the YouTube
the youtube link in the description box
alright streaming and posting stuff
yummy foods this photo will go on the
Deep Web maybe well but I'm I'm 28 so
it's not gonna count
I'm 27 actually